the president has answered his
long-standing question over possible
tapes of his conversations with former
FBI director James Comey mr. Trump
announced yesterday I did not make and
do not have any such recordings but then
he raised new questions about Robert
Muller the Special Counsel handling the
Russia investigation Margaret Brennan is
at the White House Margaret good morning
good morning well 41 days after starting
a firestorm over possible recordings of
his conversations with fired FBI
director James Comey president Trump
douve into a new controversy just hours
before hosting a picnic for members of
Congress
we've gotten to know many of you over
the last weeks and months and develop
many friendships with politicians can
you believe it the White House had hoped
to move past the controversy surrounding
the FBI probe into Russian election
meddling and questions of whether the
president tried to influence fired FBI
director James Comey but in an interview
President Trump waded back in casting
doubt on Robert Muller the special
counsel who took over that investigation
was very very good friends with Comey
which is very bothersome so we'll have
to see I can say that the people that
have been hired are all Hillary Clinton
supporters that embrace of controversy
happened just hours after the president
returned to Twitter to end one he
started six weeks ago revealing Thursday
that he was simply bluffing when he
wrote that Comey should hope that there
are no tapes of their conversations he
posted on Twitter I have no idea whether
there are tapes or recordings of my
conversations with James Comey but I did
not make and do not have any such
recordings so you never know what's out
there but I didn't tape
I don't have any tape and I didn't take
in recent weeks the president and his
aides have been stringing along a story
about possible recordings he's not
waiting for anything when he's ready to
further discuss it he will yet the
president's tweet backfire lordy I hope
their tapes inspiring Comey to call the
president's Bluff by passing along his
memos of their conversations to the New
York Times because I thought that might
prompt the appointment of a special
counsel and so I asked a close friend of
mine to do it
of course commis bet paid off and
Special Counsel Robert Mulder's
investigation is underway Gail as for
why the president mentioned tapes in the
first place
former House Speaker Newt Gingrich said
he was trying to rattle Comey it is a
question everybody wonders about thank
you very much Margaret